denounced by newspapers a bit of an
adventurer an imaginary my mother was in
labor for five days I sort of came down
the birth canal and then turned back up
so I always have the feeling that maybe
I saw something says and releases I'm
very versatile the other way to look at
it is that I never quite got my act
together physical processes in the brain
civilized discourse all the members of
my family except me a devout Muslims
they think that I'm mad cursed as
Mary Burke growing up in the West of
Ireland I didn't know what my life would
bring me my mother very much wanted us
to stand on our own two feet to the
extreme case for pushing me out of the
car aged six I was the youngest of nine
the last to come along sat at the little
table on the side of the room human
beings recovering Catholic my mind is an
interesting place reasonably well
furnished and it ranges up and down a
host of avenues I know I have a much
keener appetite for revenge
than I do for approval if you look at
musicians oftentimes they're not very
good at sports
and they're not particularly intelligent
I grew up in a culture that was very
verbal and argumentative we had to say
10 Jews 11 opinions old hippies never
never die the hopeless optimist
descended from Kings playing with clay
and and with dolls and and theater I'm
not in the entertainment you want to be
entertained go to the circus